dude wait speaking of speaking of that
though
because wasn't that the reason why
everyone got mad at nico lol
in the beginning when she got signed to
phase or something like that she wasn't
bernie chick yeah yeah yeah or the okay
boomer chicken
yeah okay hundred thieves whatever i
don't know i don't [ __ ] know but like
she started like a war on twitter
because people found out she had a
boyfriend or something
um or am i getting that totally wrong no
i think there was that i think there
were a couple big streamers
who got outed for having boyfriends
dude you don't want to get exposed for
having a having a healthy relationship
yikes dude uh-oh jesus
for uh just picturing a bunch of twitch
mods
or like tier three sub dudes like
cruising around in a van
yeah it's like they're like storm
chasing but they're like looking for
big women streamer boyfriends now we
heard
she maybe has a boyfriend we're out here
in our dodge
caravan with all these instruments
at the top just like detecting the wind
and
male 1 and [ __ ] we're here to find out
if that's the truth
it's her and like some figure they're
going to get pinkberry
[Music]
so she got in trouble i guess like two
days ago for
this video so she work i guess she wears
like tax the rich shirts and like bernie
shirts all the time sure and then she
did a
video called my two million dollar
apartment tour sick
look how many dislikes that has how many
40 what does it say 48
000 49 000. nice and it's only funny
who uh how many likes does it have
3.8 000 those are all her tier 3 subs
yeah exactly yeah
those are how many is that 25 bucks a
month let's do the math on that
let's do the math home i'll pay her tax
i'll pay i'll pay it i'll eat her tax
i'll eat her tags
it's 95k a month before twitch split i
mean
that's who's fueling her career the
other 49 000
that showed up and didn't like it she
don't care about you yeah
she's looking at she's like yeah 3800
those are my boys yeah how do you think
i got this 2 million
is these boys right here it's also just
a really weird way to say it like
a two mil like she's leasing an
apartment mm-hmm
isn't that just a weird thing to say
like yeah here's my two million dollar
apartment tour
hey man she's trying to go to mr beast
route
i say okay boomer for one year straight
i don't know let's see this tour i'm
curious to see what this apartment looks
like
i want to know what a 2 million
apartment looks like is this in new york
yeah maybe we can watch this like no
audio if that's better
yeah and just like narrate it
here let's let's narrate it let's
you know what's up gang i'm here in my
two million dollar apartment this is
where i eat vegetables and meat
separately never together sometimes i
like to cut up people on here but that's
illegal now so
i kind of had to stop that this is
actually marble
imported straight from italy this
counter alone is worth uh
more than you've ever made in your
entire life i used to keep my broccoli
in there and then i found out that's for
wine so i had to stop doing that
um this is my coffee machine although i
tend to just put concrete mix in there
i think that's more fun this is a fridge
boo see it's a pretty like it's a pretty
normal looking apartment
it's a nice apartment but it's like a
normal looking apartment
yeah i just want to know what the 2
million dollar part is
yeah is there like a i don't know
is there like a fire station in the
middle of it oh no you know what it is
dude it's those streamer lights on the
wall
that's right that's what it is those are
actually those are two million dollars
on
amazon no the 2 million part is her
streaming rig
and this right here makes me 2 million a
year
so this apartment is worth 2 million
dollars
you know those those prism lights
are the worst [ __ ]
thing this it's just funny because
everyone has them i know
everyone first of all they're not i
don't think they're cool to begin with
but then all of a sudden you see every
single other person use them
and that would make how would how does
that still make you want to get them
you know because no offense you know
all right wait i'm waiting for the two
million dollar part
all right that's kind of like this is a
pretty nice department actually separate
laundry room
yeah that's a tuna that's a yellow
that's right that's probably what it is
right there yeah having a washer dryer
in new york
what else is it in new york you think i
mean this is pretty sick actually
bathroom with a view
chicago or some [ __ ] that's pretty wild
i mean new york that's got a window
that's why it's two million dollars
that dude that dude isn't that i said
that in one of my videos that's also
that that's always like the most
embarrassing thing
just being the person in the reflection
seeing the reflection
filming something if you're gonna do
this man hire a steady op
i put like five people in that
reflection so that [ __ ] looks
serious oh that's the two million dollar
part it's this art
and these are my two this is my two
million dollar art collection
thank you to my tier three subs for
making this for me
yeah bathroom is the best poop art you
know she said poop and pee
okay dang all right hell yeah bed close
to the floor
yep two million bucks baby tax the rich
i will eat the rich for you my queen
i will eat them we will eat all the rich
so the only rich left is you
this is my snorlax some dumb [ __ ]
tier three sub gave this to me
highly disrespectful
i don't know some [ __ ] loser with a
girlfriend sent me this [ __ ] she doesn't
even know some stinky neckbeard sent
this to me
i've never i've never used it i've never
sat on it personally
people call me streamer i refer to
myself as a farmer because it's nothing
but
onions in my chat these guys do not
shower
yeah some onion paid for this bed
and these towels
oh man please get out the reflection
listen filming in here but don't be in
the reflection but show them this mirror
but also don't show yourself
[Laughter]
yeah there's another super sticky face
out of the
out of the mirror dude we can see your
stupid face in the mirror dude
dumb [ __ ] face sorry queen
[Laughter]
oh man
oh man i'm dead man i'm dead
jeez bro how many closets that's the 2
million part multiple closets
i don't know dog this like
miscellaneous the one that sam sent
oh oh yeah we should take a look at
speaking of gamer houses we should peep
this game
our house the thing is like with i guess
like with house tours like this and
stuff like that and
also like no no hate on her yeah
she got intro i didn't really look too
much into it i just saw that the video
had a bunch of dislikes and i was like
it's funny that she used to wear
that as like a fashion statement and now
she's flexing this two million dollar
apartment i mean that's that's as far as
i looked into it listen man but i think
sorry guys there's no gatekeeping on
bernie jeff bezos likes bernie
yeah right yeah yeah okay you could be a
billionaire like bernie yeah that's fair
yeah you could own a spaceship company
and wear a bernie t-shirt yeah exactly
that's the rich yeah whatever
eat me eat me eat me up i am looking
pretty tasty i love getting ate up
dude this one depending on who you are
you could take a bite of me
i just think it just reminds me of that
uh who was who was the
that gaming group that we made fun of
their house tour
in the bonus oh the san diego chargers
no [ __ ] water
oh broncos denver broncos no gaming
yeah yeah dude come on yeah okay
seriously you know what i'm saying i'm
milwaukee brewers
formula one what was the one percent of
one percent yeah remember that whenever
someone
flexes uh you know does like a youtube
house tour you know like especially now
where that like genre is blowing the
[ __ ] up
yeah like real estate agents doing crazy
tours of these incredible houses
yeah and then youtubers go like check
out my two and it's just ikea furniture
yeah
like this is come on bro come on if
you're gonna flex
i mean that's the part i love is all
these
uh real estate youtubers who have shown
us what 50 bajillion dollars looks like
in a house yeah
so it warps your perception because now
you watch a 5 million
home you're kind of like this sucks
thanks man
i wouldn't live here no bowling really
no indoor barbecue pit
where's the club dude this sucks
where's the nightclub no operating room
basic
i can't even do surgery in this house
this house sucks
you